this is a production of Cornell
University
Thank You Nina and good afternoon
everybody thank you for joining today me
today for the summer so to give you a
little overview of what we're going to
be talking about today we're going to
I'm going to talk a little bit about
just very briefly research and botanic
gardens in general i'm getting the
masters in public art and leadership so
i want to kind of give a perspective on
that and then i'm going to jump into
some research i helped out with at the
morton arboretum in chicago last summer
i'm going to finish up by talking about
some of the research i've been involved
with while here at cornell so in botanic
gardens there's been a history of
research that's dated back about five
hundred years now with the earliest
iterations of what we'd actually
consider a botanic garden there was a
research focus at these institutions the
first kind of botanic gardens that we
really considered seeing in the in the
world where what was known as the
physics gardens and these were gardens
that were associated with universities
and usually primary and primarily were
focused on teaching students about
medicinal plants and for for doctors who
were studying so the first gardens to be
established were in Italy at the
university of pisa and even from back in
this date we see that research has been
important part of what they do stepping
into the more modern day some of the
research that we see that is kind of
traditionally happened at botanic
gardens has really been work mostly
around systematics so looking at
phylogenetic relationships of plants and
classification particularly with plant
or exploration and the work that was
going on of bringing plants from other
parts of the world in classifying them
as well as floor istics floor istics
being looking at plants from the
perspective of biogeography and the
distribution of the different species
and what affects speciation in this way
and this work is of course been
supported by herbarium work the drying
of physical plants to do this kind of
taxonomic description but then also
increasingly with living collections so
bringing seed back or living plants and
growing the modding collections and
using them for this type of study
kind of more some more modern focuses
that we're starting to see more garden
sprint emphasis on is definitely
conservation biology and the disciplines
that go on within that Chicago Botanic
Garden and Missouri Botanic Garden being
two examples of gardens that have a
strong focus on plant conservation and
the associate fields and of course
horticultural research has also been an
important topic that Botanic Gardens
have played a very active role in like I
mentioned particularly with plant
exploration going to new parts of the
world bringing plants back and then with
that subsequent plant introduction and
we grow these plants on in our living
collections we start we also gives us an
opportunity for plant evaluation such as
disease screening or pest screening and
this is in many ways tied into plant
breeding programs and really gardens
have start to become more just a place a
nice place to go visit and see plants
from around the world but we're starting
more and more to consider them as what
we consider a germ plasm repository
where these wild collected plants are
representations of their wild
populations which can then be used for
study conservation or plant briefing as
I mentioned so it's a very brief
overview of review of research and
botanic gardens and with that I'm going
to transition into talk a little bit
about the work I did the more in
arboretum for people who aren't familiar
with the public garden leadership
program between your first in the second
year all the fellows in the program go
to somewhere in the United States and
participate in the internship I found
myself at the morton arboretum for a
number of reasons they've got an
excellent plant collection that I was
very interested in interacting with but
the more an arboretum to give a general
overview is 1700 acres so quite a large
garden and it's more than just the
Arboretum they focus on more than plants
they have natural areas as well as
prairies a number of formal gardens to
such as a children's garden which is a
great way to diversify your gardens to
get different types of audiences to come
and visit now so I have some other
specialized Gardens like a hedge guard
in fragrance garden they have a 27
million dollar annual budget employ over
350 employees including part-time and
seasonal and this garden was established
in 1922 by join mark martin
and people will typically know the
Morton name as the as the salt Empire
and people it in that industry and at
the more in arboretum they've got many
thousands living plants but they have
for 40 100 different specific taxes so
different species or subspecies growing
on the ground and the bourne Arboretum
was an interesting place to go because
of their living collections and because
it is such a widely visited garden but
they also have a very well-developed
research program at the morton arboretum
and they focus on a broad number of
disciplines from plant systematics some
of our more traditional research we'd
find in gardens to forest ecology
actually Robert Fahey Bob Fahey who's
the son of tim faye hughes who some
folks might be familiar with and Natural
Resources works there they also focus on
plant conservation or bora culture root
biology and the lab I was most
interested in working with was the urban
soils lab so dr. Bryant Sharon Brock
heads up the math soil science
laboratory and will make their lab a
little bit interesting is they have a
number of different areas of research
interest but they really focus on urban
soils and urban ecosystems as their
central focus such as an urban ecology
and biochemistry and assessment and
relation of urban soils they also do
some focus on forest management as well
as Prairie studies and these two kind of
last two areas the Prairie ecology and
forest management are is actually a lot
of the research that gets done
physically on the grounds at the morton
arboretum so it's something that makes
them a little different as well is that
they use their landscape and view their
landscape as a living laboratory and to
give a kind of overview of what Brian
slab look like because it is a little
different than what we tend to see in
the academic setting is that Bryant has
been there for five years he's done he's
but was 12 publications and done 50
through presentations at this point but
one of the major difference is is that
there's only two employees in the lab
his lab manager and himself and he's
works with graduate students but not
specifically as chairs for committees
more kind of tan gently like the way
he's worked with me and he does sit on
some committees but where he kind of
makes up the
difference and productivity that
graduate students will bring to a lab is
in his use of volunteers so in five
years he's used his hat ended up having
over 150 volunteers in his lab as well
as 41 interns yeah and he'll enlist
he'll enlist anyone that he can
including his children to do have work
and this is something that is you know
volunteers or something that Botanic
Gardens heavily used to help fulfill
their work and their missions and this
is just one example because interesting
one of how his lab can still be very
productive but in a slightly different
context and what we may be familiar with
so jumping into urban soils which is
going to be what we talked about for the
remainder of this talk I'm going to read
this definition because I think it
really sums up what urban soils are
urban soils are non-agricultural
man-made surface layer more than 50
centimeters thick that have been
produced by a mixing filling or
contamination of land in urban or
suburban areas so really what we're
talking about here is we're talking
about soils that aren't agricultural
aren't found in a natural ecosystem and
typically in one way or another are
adversely or are impacted by human use
or human presence and why is this an
important area of study it's important
area of study particular the United
States because in the next 40 years were
projected to have five percent more
urban areas in the United States alone
and humans have unique impacts that
alter the soils biogeochemical processes
and really make them distinct and unique
system so in surveys of urban soils that
have been done we tend to see a suite of
characteristics that we will find such
as high bulk densities decreases in
organic matter poor structure high pH
low water holding capacity decrease in
aggregate stability inadequate soil
depth for root growth and a decrease in
microbial biomass
so when I was at the morton arboretum I
specifically helped out with the Chicago
urban forestry study and the Chicago
urban forestry study was a joint study
between the Morton Arboretum and the US
Department of Agriculture and there's
two main p is on it was Bryant Sharon
Brock in the urban soil science lab as
well as Bob Fahey and forest ecology I'm
primarily going to be talking about this
first area the second area Robert Fahey
was mostly looking using
dendrochronology techniques to look at
how the urban forest was responding to
different differences in different
climatic events so particularly drought
you want to see how the force responding
to that and the justification for the
study is that there had been no
comprehensive study of carbon storage
that have been conducted in an urban
system based on different land-use types
and then looking at the soils both in a
shallow 20 centimetres as well as deep
up to a meter in depth and in some
places deeper than that even and this is
important because in the urban
environment soils themself make up the
single largest terrestrial sink of
carbon with up to sixty four percent
followed by vegetation which are two
factors that we considered in this study
so looking at about eighty four percent
of all the carbon that cycles in the
urban system in a study that was
conducted in 2000 by joga beam Jackson
they looked at three different natural
land ecosystems land types and looked at
how carbon was distributed within the
top centimeter of soil based on these
three through sri LAN types and what
they found from this initial study was
that in shrublands you had a larger
percentage of carbon distributed in the
deeper part of your soils on one end of
the spectrum while in forests and forest
lands you ended up with carbon primarily
in your top 20 centimeters of soil and
this was mostly explained in the
shrubland systems as by how deep the
roots were going and turning over in the
soil and with the forest like in
deciduous forests with leafs or coarse
woody debris accumulating you find a
higher carbon in the
top 20 centimeters so Brian kind of
looked at this idea and thought about
where he could wear it could move
forward with it and the two types of
carbon that we wanted to look at in
these systems were organic carbon as
most people will be familiar with our
carbon that's derived from a living
source interplan or animal and living in
dead microorganisms but he also wanted
to look at inorganic carbon which in
soils to be your firm's to carbon found
in a carbonate form which is derived
from mineral parent material and in
urban systems in particular organic
inorganic carbon is more of a question
of protection and is about sequestration
with all the disturbances that go on on
urban ecosystems by exposing these
inorganic carbon deposits you can
actually create a source for carbon into
the atmosphere versus a sink as we may
think about with organic cotton so
there's a number of factors in
particular that affect carbon cycling
within these soils and what I want to
point out here is that all the ones that
I put stars next to from here on down
are different factors that can be
affected by land management or by just
how we we use our land our presence on
it and so carbon cycling within the
shallow part of our soil is primarily
derived from organic carbon we see high
rates of turnover here and these are
sensitive to human management and
typically found in your organic or
you're a horizons where deeper beyond 20
centimeters it's a slower turnover rate
you find more of your inorganic carbon
sources and you can also find organic
sources and this is where you start to
find your a horizons your horizons and
your B horizons as well so to understand
the framework of how the morn arboretum
wanted to construct the study looking at
carbon based on land use they went back
to a study that was conducted in 2010
also supported by the more in arboretum
2010 the morn Arboretum conducted a tree
census of the Chicagoland region and
what the tree census was is they
selected the seven counties around
Chicago as well as the city itself and
they generated 2076 random
they went out to each of these plots and
they looked at the characterize the
plots based on two sets of criteria they
looked at the plot information so what
was the land being used for as well as
percent tree cover shrub cover and the
shrub species and then also when they
found trees they would look at the trees
specifically they would characterize the
species the stem diameter tree height
crown height and its general health how
much myth missing foliage or dieback had
occurred crown light exposure and as
well as distance to infrastructure or
other buildings and they took all this
information and they put it they used it
in the eye tree model which for people
who aren't familiar with this is a model
created by the USDA and used by urban
foresters or city planners to quantify
the structure of urban forests within a
municipality town and what this model
does is one it gives us a breakdown of
all the different species and and how
much can be covered perhaps you're
finding within the New York City but it
also puts terms it puts it in terms of
ecosystem services derived in a monetary
value there's it can be a way to justify
having an urban forest and maintaining
it and diversifying it so they use this
model and create all this data and so
Brian took this information and they
decided to for this carbon study to take
a subset of these different land-use
types so these are all the different
land-use types that we looked at in the
greater chicagoland region that we
wanted to assess for carbon cycling in
those systems so we took a number of
different types of samples we took deep
samples using this it's hard to see this
picture a large soil sampler that takes
samples down to a meter in depth we took
shallow samples down to 20 centimeters
as well as our literally or whatever is
primarily on the top of the soil and we
brought these back to the lab and based
on we look at each of the deep soil
profiles based on horizons and
characterize them based on color pH
texture bulk density so
moisture we would also take our litter
extracted and we would set them up and
extract any of the invertebrates as
maybe an additional part of the study
that they'll be looking at in the future
so we looked at carbon in three
different ways we looked at our
inorganic and organic carbon with
elemental analysis and gas
chromatography and we looked at our
organic carbon particularly in two ways
one is particular organic matter and the
other one is using active carbon I'm
going to talk about these these two
tests so a particulate organic matter is
a way of quantifying and looking at
organic matter based on size so what you
do is you you take your organic matter
and divide it from your your sand silt
signore clays and you fracturing them
into different size classes each of
these signs there's four different size
classes through your representative here
the other one being smallest organic
matter that's associated with your soul
your silts in your clays your organo
mineral complexed organic matter and the
third goes is that the the the depending
on the different size classes each size
class has a different residency time in
the soil with anywhere from our litter
soil organic matter for being yes less
than a year door to our organo mineral
complexed organic matter being anywhere
from four hundred to a thousand years
Bryant had in a previous study in the
past where he looked at time since
disturbance of sites so how long it had
been since a site had been in an urban
ecosystem had been kind of created or
established and looked at a particulate
organic matter and found that this
course particular organic matter
particularly on the one to two years was
a very good indicator for microbial
biomass microbial biomass carbon as well
as nitrogen mineralization so this
information if you used could be helped
to use and figure out nitrogen
calculations for street trees as the
sharing one so this is one way of
looking at organic matter that the
Sharon Brock lab is very very fond of
and the other technique that we used was
the active carbon test
so for folks who are familiar with the
soil health test here at Cornell this is
the preferred method that they use it's
a potassium permanganate oxidation
process and this has really started to
becoming in favor for looking at our our
labile organic matter our organic matter
that turns over quickly in the soil
because it's really easy to conduct it's
on a color metric scale and they've
known that sensitive to changes in
management techniques so we see that it
correlates well with basal respiration
aggregation and microbial biomass and so
all this information that the Shamrock
work lab is working on is going to be
cycled into the I tree model itself and
used to build a carbon model for soils
based on land-use type just like the I
tree model had been used to create
ecosystem services for above-ground
biomass so that about sums up the work
that I did at the morton arboretum or is
involved with and I'm going to
transition now to talk about the
research I've been doing while I've been
at Cornell so for folks the semi spoke
earlier this year what I've been working
on while I've been here I've been
working in neenah bassick and Don R a
cow and Harold vanasse on the scoop and
dump technique of soil remediation and
this technique is pretty much just what
it sounds we we come in we take compost
we put it on impacted soils or compacted
soils at a rate of six to eight inches
and then we come in with a backhoe
physically lift it up and drop it and
what this creates as a heterogeneous oil
mixture that landscape plants can be
directly planted into and then after
that after the planting mulch is added
every year as you would find in most
landscaping contexts and this technique
was developed based on to kind of
studies the first one being a study done
in 1991 bike I rolf who came in without
adding organic matter just using a
backhoe to physically fracture soils and
what he found when he did this looking
at so a quality he found that soil bulk
density decreased that pore volume
increase and soil resistance
so using a penetrometer in that soil
also decreased secondly a study done
finished up in 2007 by Nina basak and
Angela Riven shield looked at using
different types of organic amendments
and seeing how those affected soil bulk
densities and soil porosities and that's
how we came up with using this thirty
three percent organic matter as an ideal
amendment so the scoop and dump
technique has had a legacy of practice
on the Cornell campus for we're going on
to your 14 now at this point every year
in neenah basyx creating the urban
eating class the this is a year-long
course insight establishment of plants
and woody plant ID the the class will
design create an install a new garden
and we've been doing this technique for
more than 12 years lice or for 12 years
when I started and it has been used to
restore sites such as some people will
recognize this this is outside of man
library when it was under construction
and severely impacted soils we're occur
during this process and here's a picture
taken even a couple years ago of what
the landscape looks like now and another
one so we we had seen that anecdotally
we knew it was working we had some some
research to back it up but we wanted to
take it another step further and really
see what the changes and so quality had
occurred based on using this technique
so in the first part of our study we
selected six sites representing 12 years
to be studied for all in our scoop and
dump soils and we selected for sites
that were in close proximity to our
study sites that had gone through
similar disturbance regimes and could be
used as a control or as a contrast and
we use the soil health test to look at
physical biological and chemical aspects
of the soil in our initial study and the
way we sampled is we would we would dig
into our scoop and dump soil and we
would sample that and then we'd go below
our scoop and dump layer into our sub
soil and we'd also sample that and then
for our controls at
you would take samples at equal depths
to our scuba dump as well as our
subsoils so looking at soil resistance
so coming in with a with a calibrated
penetrometer and doing it all shortly
after rain falls are very close to field
capacity for soil moisture we saw that
in our scoop and dump soils that we
started to see root limiting PSI or root
looming resistance I should say in our
scoop and dump soil right around 25
centimeters in depth compared to our
unamended soils we found them right
around nine centimeters in depth so
about a three-fold increase in available
root depth that we were finding in our
remediated sites as I mentioned we look
at this study in two ways we looked at
in a compare and contrast with our unruh
mediated to our immediate sites we also
looked at it over time since we've been
doing this practice for years and over
time we saw that well density decreased
over time dr0 being over here we also
noticed that are we found that are
potentially mineralize about nitrogen
had increased over time as well as our
active carbon and this was exciting to
see and certainly make sense with the
potential mineralized well nitrogen act
of carbon active carbon being a food
source for soil microorganisms and
organisms that are involved in nitrogen
mineralization with the potential
mineral nitrogen increases we see and
the the aggregate are sorry the bulk
density increase was also exciting to
see particularly with our increase in
aggregate stability we were saying that
we were creating lower bulk density
soils but they're also being maintained
by this improvement in structure
improvement in pore space so to
summarize other findings we found from
this initial study we found also
increase aggregate stability we found
increased available water holding
capacity increased total organic matter
increased potentially mineralized well
nitrogen bulk densities as well as
active carbon
and this is kind of a common scene of
what what we would find in many of our
sites this site had only been installed
one year when we looked at it but this
is a profile difference between our
scoop and dump soils compared to the
subsoil and you can see you know we
found this all across the site that once
we get down to that sub soil which had
higher bulk densities typically we would
see the roots just start to move
sideways instead of continuing to move
down so we took all this information and
we wanted to think about how plants were
grown in this type of environment and do
a study to follow up what we learned in
our first section so with that we came
up with a soil container study we wanted
to conduct to look at how the plants how
plants themselves would respond to these
different soil mediums so we hypothesize
that plants grown in the scoop and dump
soil will have increased biomass and
this increased biomass will be
correlated with our reduced bulk density
are improved bulk density and then we
also hypothesized that because of our
increased water holding capacity the
plants grow in our scoop and dump soil
would have a better capability of
dealing with drought particularly in
stomatal conductance as well as
photosynthesis compared to our unamended
soils so we took a subset of the sites
we used before we selected three sites
and we selected three controls that went
along with them and we went out into the
landscape and we took large PVC cores
and and in this case we used to how to
use a backhoe to drive these into the
ground and pull them up and this is the
best available technique we have at
getting as close to undisturbed soil
samples as as possible perhaps a slight
over estimate but it's the best we work
with we didn't have to use a backhoe in
our scoop and dump sites because the
both density was decreased so is a
little easier to sample and so we
selected a woody plant to grow in them
we selected ficus benjamina and we
wanted to use we ended up using ficus
benjamina one because it's known in
tropical regions of the world for being
a street tree as we can
see in this picture here and we also
want to use it to get around the winter
dormancy issue if we had selected a
North American temperate species which
would have been ideal but we were
working over the winter so so we
selected if I could spend jamana
evergreen and had tissue cultured plants
donated to us from sunshine horticulture
in Florida all very pretty consistent
size when we got them so we collected
these soils outside we brought them into
the greenhouse for a short period and
planted the ficus directly into the
different types of soils and shortly
after that we move them into growth
chambers and allowed them to grow for
three and a half months before we
decided to conduct our drought study in
the end we ended up using 15 soils that
had been remediated and 15 soils that
ribbon Remedia of the scoop and dump and
15 that had had not been remediated for
our study and we subjected them to a
period of 26 days of drought and before
we started the study what we did is we
got the plants up to field capacity so
we brought them up to a high point of
water holding and then let them drain
and then wrap them in bags so that
really only the only water there would
be lost is through transpiration and not
evaporation so our measurements that we
want to look at in the study were root
and shoot biomass total leaf area and
leaf water potential at pre dawn and the
soils characteristics that we want to
look at where gravimetric water content
volumetric water content and texture
water holding capacity total organic
matter and bulk density and in terms of
gas exchange we looked at photosynthesis
as well as stone model conductance so
what we ended up finding from our study
was that our leaf area in our scoop and
dump soils over here was was greatly
increased almost twofold compared to our
unamended soils so much more leaf area
we found that our route dry weight was
significantly increased in our scoop and
dump soils compared to our unamended
soils as well as our shoot dry weight
was significantly higher in our scoop
and dem soils compared to our unamended
soils we also looked at bulk density
since this has been a major question of
our study and we found it in our scoop
and dump soils they were significantly
lower than our unamended and for folks
that aren't familiar bulk density bulk
density is a measurement of weight over
volume so grams per centimeter cubed and
a study done by data and warrington had
established a relationship between
different textural classes and root
limiting bulk densities and what they
found is that for your sands you can get
up to bulk densities around 1.75 grams
per centimeters cubed before you end up
finding reduced bulk densities and for
silts and Clay's it's around 1.4 so
considering again that our scoop and
dump soils were well below this 1.4
threshold was very good to see and then
our unamended soils are definitely
getting into their range of root
limiting bulk densities and we don't
have the textures back from our study
yet but we'll be able to look at those
compared to these once those final tests
are completed so we did our linear
regression looking at our dry weight
shoots with our bulk densities now we
see a clear relationship here and if we
overlay this with our different types of
treatments or scoop and dump soils on
the left here and our and our unamended
we see a clear relationship between the
bulk density and this improved scoop and
dump creating allowing for more shoots
to be ground and this line here
represents root limiting bulk density I
really strikingly cutting them right
down the middle there
so we saw this relationship as well with
our roots here's it with the overlay
again and we also saw this relationship
with our leaf area and again with this
overlay and so when we destructively
harvested these we obviously noticed
certainly a much larger volume of roots
and our scoop and dump comparatively
tour unamended soils but one pattern
that was very consistent here are
pictures from our unamended sites was
you can see from how I'm holding up
these roots right here is that in our
unamended soils right here is kind of
where we planted where the plug was that
we plant into the soils themselves and a
very consistent pattern where the roots
growing up across the top and then
escaping down the sides of the
containers right down here in an area
that had perhaps a little extra space in
it or do not have the same type of bulk
dad say as we found in the soil so this
was a very very consistent pattern and
one that's interesting to think about as
we you know if we since we did this in
containers in the landscape roots
probably wouldn't have this or they
certainly wouldn't have this container
or reduced area where they would be able
to go down so we actually think that our
roots are a bit over an over estimate
compared to our scoop and dump it was
also very interesting to look at the
root exploration in our scoop and dump
soils we really saw that our roots were
really exploring and taking advantage of
this increased structure with our
aggregate stability and able to find
those pore spaces and really work their
way through and it was interesting
pulling them apart because we take a lot
more work to break up the aggregates and
actually free the roots from the system
compared to and our unamended soils or
pretty much you'd start to break it
apart and the soils would just all fall
away the plant was not holding very much
on to them because of this decrease in
structure and we're exploration
throughout the soils
so looking at our leaf water potentials
this is days of drought on the bottom
here we see that as in both the
unamended and the scoop and dump soils
that that really there wasn't much
different in how these plants were
responding to drought in terms of leaf
water potentials now we certainly saw a
strong spike after day 16 of our
potentials starting to get really
negative at this point and this was a
fairly consistent pattern that we saw
with our photosynthetic rate and our gas
exchange measurements as well we're both
the plants there was no significant
differences in over the course of the
drydown experiment showing a difference
in photosynthetic rate as well as still
model conductance was also had no
significant differences between the two
and we started to think about this and
look at this we also looked at like I
said water loss of the soils themselves
over time and the red up here is scoop
and dump soils and the blue is unamended
and this is a cumulative water loss over
time and with this what we see is that
the scuba dump soils did in fact hold
and lose more water compared to our
unamended which was cooperated with our
available increase in available water
holding capacity where we lost a point 0
9 8 kilograms of water over the course
of 26 days well about a little more than
half that in our unamended soils just
point 65 kilograms of water loss
and looking at our water loss between
days we also saw that as there were
significant differences between days 1
and day 6 16 in terms of amount of water
loss between days with our scoop and
dump soils losing more water compared to
our unamended and then that that
difference no longer occurs after day 21
and day 26 and so looking all this it
starts to make more sense that even
though our scoop and dump soils held
more water and we did see an increase in
both root growth as well as total leaf
area that there is a increase in
stomatal conductance an increase in in
transpiration which really seemed to
explain driving this pattern between our
different soil amendments and with that
I'd like to thank my committee and
everyone else who's been a part of my
research progress here as well as the
morton arboretum and i'm happy to answer
any questions
I just like to make sure I was
understanding edge but it seemed to me
like to have two types of comparisons in
your study of the scoop end up so so one
was the unamended versus to scoop and
done but then also the scoop and dumps
against each other over time so so okay
it was so quick that I didn't play up to
see you / increasing tension mineralize
will nitrogen active carbon and
decreasing bulk density the longer
orbiter oh that's so interesting so oh
so what do you make of that well I think
the authentic certainly makes sense with
with you know the producer of the car
broke that down in terms of loosening
the soil and maintaining that creating
more floor space and it also thinking
about with the increased enacted
stability 1 speed 0 so i'll have to
loosen and that increases structure
make sense in terms of quality or more
space between the different areas
in terms of the active carbon I think
that materna make sense with a huge
amount of organic matter that we input
initially as well as the continued
because preferential
so over time as we continue
so it kind of seems like that initial
remediation like that's emotion kind of
a virtuous cycle like once you have
better aggregation it can sequester more
Cartman it certainly can't afford yeah
because I mean I would expect the
immediate difference between the two
treatments that that increase over time
is very interesting well that's
something that you do tend to see also
like I mentioned this to disturb before
we look dead time since disturbance that
after 25 years you start to see so I'll
start to cycle back
so even without doing to question your
landscape
I have a question about the that same
primers say so did you have the same
species and all of these landscapes so
clearly your plant material would affect
your soil characteristics as well
particularly if that landscape has been
established for some period of time so
were you always sampling near the same
species or an area no plants or how did
that work we totally we we ran transects
through our plots at certain intervals
to reach one so we weren't as
this first day was marked to serve a
look at what really
choose
cuz I'm looking at if I am more time to
comment you know 13 14 years
every year
one species
but we didn't do that now was something
that we did look at in terms of
Steve area
both and finding solutions
the same that's part of their greatest
not just create diversity learning
opportunities for students in the class
so
and maybe a more traditional context of
species
Oh
vs here
it is the thinnest the dumps little
higher transpiration rates larger
entities why was this water potential
lower and why wasn't the photosynthesis
know they've drawn more water or can
yeah I mean for you know well I think it
makes sense if you think about the total
area in terms of stomatal conductance at
least we had greater leaf area and our
scuba done soils almost twice as much so
I was driving transpiration what's your
blown off more water make this little
drier and right what ok so our soils had
more even so even though they had more
area can hide or water will be passed
easing in our students of soils so
so I had a session on a totally
different topic but you also touched on
so you talked about the importance of
volunteers in the botanical gardens
research and I'm really interested to
know what you think about if and how of
the principal investigators in context
like that can create a valuable kind of
educational and or professional
development experience that those
volunteers for volunteers I mean I can
see how it could be you know very much a
kind of grunt work thing where you don't
get much out of it but I can also see
how you could shape it to be something
really transport mantilla and I was
interesting about the price ladder
particular because of all the labs out
more and I'm certain he took advantage
of volunteers plate and the type of
people that volunteer for really across
the board you know like you got his kids
time maybe they're across from people
who are in you know college for you to
gain experience to do you yet retired
chemistry lab just wanted to
you know do something with their time
and can take their skill to use and so
for him it's become a very effective
tool and also he's he's been habitable
resources and because it happens people
such depth of knowledge
if a bring altered
so yeah I don't know exactly but it
isn't a botanic gardens there's an
attrition
music volunteers
you know I tried to think about how to
apply potential parties are Commission
based organization is an equal and
visiting having a
experience that and it's a different
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu